bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono favi dei oggi siamo
su slider woods un videogame che mi
state consigliando anche questo da
secoli
con questo dovremmo avere praticamente
finito e videogames che mi state non si
andò da da anni e millenni tranne scp
che andrò a fare anche quello più avanti
comunque
life in the city sapete come agisco io
quando trovo delle note dei videogiochi
horror così perfetto va beh non importa
della trama tanto un video phone
videogame horror sempre in d quindi
penso che voi aspettiate soltanto gli
spaventi e invece aspetto soltanto di
morire giovane
ci siamo risvegliati in una casa come al
solito senza sapere perché mi avete
detto che questo slider è diverso dagli
altri perché ha una storia infatti
adesso fatto la modalità storia non ha
idea di che cosa sia per andare in
contrario spero che sia fatto abbastanza
decentemente cosa questo o flashlight
come facciamo senza la nostra adorata
torcia come si come si equipaggiavano ok
già non so come si equipaggia torcia
però io volentieri mi farei un caffè al
microonde e vabbè la lavatrice in cucina
poi me lo spiegate ma non importa da
eugenie qua perché sono siamo ore ore
nello stesso posto
come si esce questo nokia che bello ma
che bel giardino michia vedo niente
madonna senza torcia proprio buio presto
fantastico una bicicletta che in questo
caso potrebbe anche essere utile ma noi
lasciamo la pure lì
proseguiamo senza bene la foresta è il
territorio classico dello slider quindi
lui gioca in casa come al solito ho
sentito qualcosa e spero che sia un
coniglio
sì dai era un coniglio mettiamola così
e sempre il coniglio state tranquilli
oggi un po agitato ok ok non è un
coniglio non è un coniglio non è un
coniglio feel good eye super league get
back home
sì sì sì torniamo a casa torniamo a casa
che è meglio
bene si è già stancato bene fantastico
ragazzi siamo in uno slider e si capisce
subito che dopo due metri di corsa il
personaggio cade a terra
stanco devo sentirmi forno pasta domjan
no mia mi ha intrappolato fuori stronzo
mi ha afferrato la porta c'è una nota
che cosa sto facendo qui non lo so però
io sono preoccupanti alla finestra che
aperta tra l'altro ecc e la finestra
aperta però è solo una texture purtroppo
da questo nostro chef site west
probabilmente devo andare necron del
construction site west
non ho idea di dove sia ma penso che sia
ad ovest appunto la nota non la prendono
bene
e dov'era andato prima credo si muove se
a ovest orientato però in che modo non
sono ragazzi continuiamo dove eravamo
prima perché dovrebbe essere rovers
credo non ci ama c'è la bussola che
idiota e in alto a destra l'avevo vista
e allora noi dall'altra parte perfetto
bene ok ragazzi
la cosa bella è che appunto questo
slider ha una trama e quindi avete detto
che si può anche salvare quindi penso
che lo finirò episodi appunto
underground tunnel se non che mi ispiri
però il bando di qua siccome ambiente
abbastanza monotono nel senso che
classici alberi tutto buio non si vede
niente
non devo andare là però ci andrei
volentieri perché ha chiuso stupì
tranquillo bene con struscia ok ci siamo
ragazzi construction zon
c'è qualcosa c'è qualcuno di ostile no
perfetto
c'è una pala prendi la palla e tira
mente stavo lander no no non ti
difendere subisci come sempre ok
devo mica e 3 qua dentro ok its
lightyear e vabbè però nicchia non è
durato niente
vabbè comunque c'era scritto che c'è la
luce questo l'avevo intuito anche cosa
presso che palle ok si è chiuso da solo
perfetto chiave ho trovato la chiave per
i tuoi nei sotterranei li ho visti prima
quindi andiamoci la chiave inglese può
esserti sempre utile come autodifesa ma
non prenderla usciamo ragazzi ve lo
lascio in descrizione come al solito mi
dimentico di dirlo ma poi lo sapete già
comunque che ve lo lascio quindi
non c'è bisogno che lo ripeta sempre
comunque c'è ok questo perfetto
underground tunnels fa che si apra ok
bene ragazzi siamo entrati in penombra
ragazzi sembra veramente penombra sorso
proposto che scendiamo salvataggio o uno
slider in cui si salva incredibile
ok ragazzi mi sembra molto più
tranquillo mi sembra un unione tra le
vecchie mappe this lander c'è tra tutte
le mappe di rendere quelle tutte uguali
che uscivano questo videogame insieme
un'unione tra tutte quante diciamo
perché si cambia di zona in zona
spero che non ci sia lo svenderà anche
qui e a quanto pare no però è tutto
chiuso
ho sentito il rumore che proveniva di
qua quindi noi andiamo di qua
destra o sinistra cos'è a è
semplicemente una perdita di gas
quindi niente uscita ma da lì ci sono
arrivato semplicemente girato in tondo
credo ragazzi e miss orientare in modo
da dovete sentito anche voi
ok c'è un rumore che non mi piace per
niente che proviene da quella porta ma
noi ci entriamo lo stesso enit find
switch domande ok
devo devo trovare un una leva un
qualcosa bene non so che cosa devo fare
ma ci sarà sicuramente una porta in
qualcosa ok perfetto il rumore
fastidiosissimo se n'è andato cos'è sta
roba
una porta con codice numerico come ho
detto il codice però sa chi sono io ci
sono i numeri sulla tastiera ragazzi che
servono a qualcosa evidentemente non li
hanno messi per caso comunque è tutto
chiuso a meno che questa ma c'è un altro
codice numerico e pazienza
usciamo di qui c'è una scatola che non
si può capitare ma cos'è questo o forse
ho trovato lo switch perfetto ragazzi ho
aperto la porta si è calmato il
sottofondo cioè prima c'era un'atmosfera
tipo paurosissimo adesso se non ci non
sento più niente e preferivo prima
sinceramente perché quando non sento
niente mica go addosso a prescindere
ok è tutto dritto si sia aperto ragazzi
sia aperto un cacciavite non lo prendere
non ti serve autodifesa per i remember
di snoop dogg for the doors 232 perfetto
ragazzi abbiamo il codice delle porte
armadietti che non si aprono e
nient'altro bene ragazzine o la prima
porta
corriamo perché secondo me sta per
succedere qualcosa di brutto sostò
presentimento quant'era che con qual era
il codice ragazzi 2 3 2 o 3 2
no 232 ok ragazzi la mia memoria è
fantastica
io non entro qui dentro io qui dentro
non ci entro ragazzi non c entro ma
entriamoci perfetto c'è nessuno no ero
ok chiuditi però chiudi la porta
chiudila la porta ragazzino con si
chiude
e questo non è rassicurante però va bene
così questo salire no vero cosa devo
fare qui qual è il mio obiettivo a c'è
un'altra nota che con tra l'altro codice
forse no note a caso che non leggo
ragazzi comunque adesso in avanti vi
lascio almeno un secondo da quando apro
le note così se qualcuno se le vuole
leggere può leggerle questo per quanto
riguarda i videogiochi in di veloci tipo
slider essa chiave laddove spuntata il
cup il giorno l'avevo vista uil snello
di orso ma che schifo ragazzi ma perché
esse frasi ok ragazzi progresso
progressivi salvaggio trovato una chiave
si è spenta la luce si è spenta la luce
si spegne
facciamo
siamo di qua usciamo riuscita ragazzi in
uscita non c'è l'uscita da dove da dove
si esce ragazzi no no no no no no per
favore no per favore no ok ok ok ok ok
che calmi calmi calmi se se se faccio il
giro non se ne accorge riescono
rigirarlo perché lo slider è stupido
perfetto non lo vedo più però devo
andare di qua perché devo uscire duri a
mostri di qua come faccio uscire ragazzi
non so come farò uscire se deve uscire
da da dove sono arrivato no non l'ho
capito
oddio mi guardi carico va benissimo ok
perfetto perfetto calmissimi ragazzi
calmi è tutto a posto cosa devo fare
ai feel like i'm getting secca sì anche
a me viene da vomitare spesso appena
finito di giocare al handala mi viene
sempre a vomitare per gli spaventi che
ho preso cos'è sta roba
ok la scritta lowes lander
non lo so lo stava scritto da lander
ragazzi ma io di qua devo andarmene
assolutamente o una chiave che non ho la
più pallida idea di che cosa possa
aprire forse sta in questo cancello qui
cos'è richardson so milsom non so che
cosa vuol dire a nixon film ok
che cazzo pezzo di merda no ok ragazzi
non voglio fare commenti su quello che
ha appena successo però no no di nuovo
qui no ragazzi
no no no vi prego no di qua almeno
potevate farmi sposare fuori ok va bene
321 a nanna ok ragazzi
ok usciamo di qua
no perché è già stanco non ho neanche
corso ok
ok
sinistra destra destra c'è gente che lo
vedo lo vedo lo vedo lo vedo via via
perché cammini ok no no no no no no
fuori fuori fuori fuori fuori no no
salirà ok ragazzi neanche salire una
scala ma si può essere così impediti
usciamo di qua
sì sì sì sì mi andavo imitare anche a me
abbiamo capito non so che cosa devo fare
ragazzi costa chiave nella infilo neka
pranzi st chiave ragazzi non so che cosa
farmene per che cammina sentisse ti
stacchi così tanto ma prendi la bici
cioè non è neanche legata a meno che non
apra la porta qui ma non penso proprio
infatti allo ragazzi prima siamo andati
ad ovest quindi adesso provo ad andare
ad est vedo un interferenza ma non vedo
rose renderman non è un bene
non so dove andare ragazzi ho io vado
dico no no no no no no non lo vedo ma
non mi piace ok adesso lo vedo adesso
vedo corri pezzente ok perfetto c'è un
lago un lago questo non lo so se un lago
ma quella fare lì mi sta dietro
ok devo riuscire ad entrare qualche
parte veloce st chiave a qualcosa
servirà dai ok lo seminato ragazzi
incredibile non so come ho fatto però
sta chiave a qualcosa deve servire cioè
non ha senso che l'abbia presa senza che
apre niente lo stesso posto una grotta
chiusa non mi chiedete che cosa che
senso può avere una cosa del genere però
va bene
[Risate]
vado vado a caso perché tanto non so
dove andare certo sto girando la bussola
mio unico metodo diciamo per orientarmi
però non so dove andare perché è
veramente
o è immenso sto posto e pieno di zone
nuove non ha idea di che cosa il quale
sia il mio obiettivo tra l'altro però
vabbè quello sorvoliamo ragazzi sto sto
andando avanti da mezz'ora non sto
capendo niente
ok cos'è sta roba
matthew mansion no no quella quello non
è matthew non sei tu matthew non sei tu
menti vado via vado via vado via vado
via
no non mi piace che si sentono rumori
senti rumori che non mi piacciono ma mi
piace ancora meno lo slider che mi sta
appiccicato ragazzi non riesco a scolar
meno di dosso viti dai cavolo minchia eh
vabbè però dove è sempre ragazzi mi sta
raggiungendo mista c'è un altro po mi
prende non riesco a muovermi
ok ok via via via via via mia vita ap ap
qualcosa che il culo era questa
mamma mia che botta di culo era questa
la porta che apriva la chiave è
fantastico ragazzi sono riuscito ad
entrare in una casa a caso scusate il
gioco di parole ma è così
la chiave ha funzionato stenderlo
seminato salvata in automatico la
partita
continuerò nel prossimo episodio se vi è
piaciuto come al solito video lasciato
mi piace un commento anche sulla pagina
facebook che trovate sempre in
descrizioni noni mio video
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
ci vediamo prossimo video bella ragazzi